first of all thank you all for being
here thank you for that incredible funny
and thrilling film and Ryan I do have to
say having watched your work for a while
now this is not an easy thing to pull
off where it is funny thrilling
action-packed hilarious and then you
know a little whodunit mixed on top of
it talk about that journey to craft this
new thrilling story
well um well thank you guys first of all
for being here so much and Jacob thank
you for doing this and when we made the
first movie
um even while we were shooting it Daniel
and I were uh on set and just talking
about if this does okay it would be
really fun to keep doing these and
um but what made me excited about doing
them is the notion of I'm kind of
getting back to the source of what got
me excited about doing this in the first
place singing about Agatha Christie and
thinking about Agatha Christie's books
and um reality is anyone who's actually
a fan of Christie's books knows she was
taking wild swings in different
directions with every single book she
was mixing up genres she was flipping
stuff on its hedge she was writing to
her pres the presence Society it's not
and so anyway all of that to say it was
it was thrilling for me the idea of kind
of leaning into that tradition and
saying as opposed to continuing the last
one let's let's make an entirely new
thing let's surprise ourselves and and
hopefully the audience
like the last one are I would say
heroine of this is played by an
incomparable incredible vivacious
actress who we just cannot take our eyes
off on screen let's give it up for Andy
what was it about Andy and that's all
we'll say for now that that really
attracted you to this role and maybe the
duality of it I just think like it just
crosses Generations I think the
character that we're playing represents
like you said
um a lot of you know powerful strong
black women who you know when you look
on the heavier side of it are overlooked
pushed to the margins ideas stolen and
um it just really felt great breaking
all that damn glass you know serious
feelings seriously though yes I have to
feel most days Ryan's direction to you
just had to be have fun yeah like is
that like the best you can go bigger I
was like I can okay talk about that
freedom as an actor I mean that's the
best freedom in the world but yeah
Birdie's bold and loud and tone deaf and
all the things that I think are really
fun to play as as an actor I think the
challenge is you know what is the what
is walking that tightrope and and you
know what's what's grounding her that
makes someone that is can could be so
unlikable
um
somehow this that hilarious
um and that is obviously the great
writer talk about some of the stuff Ryan
talked about your character to make her
real that was not part of the stuff that
you guys got to stay on screen to keep
it yeah the backstory as well he has
such a clear
um idea
that you really don't need to go outside
what is there in the Bible that is the
screenplay so it's all there that you
don't really have to go off and find so
everything that I knew that was this
character Claire de Bello is already in
there everything that we all knew of who
we were going to to play was all in
there and then there's this fabulous
like limbic space when you meet the
amazing Jenny Egan the costume designer
who was like oh incredible who you know
when you go in for that first fitting
and you see that rack of clothes you it
kind of you you think okay and then that
you finally are able to meet where Ryan
between the page and where Ryan really
sees this part and that helps also kind
of clarify as it were where you're
supposed to be and then I and then this
is the first evening I got a chance to
meet Bob the way that they both together
protect performance is I'm just very
moved by so just an honor to meet you
sir and love really and all oh he's
coming yeah I definitely want to talk
about his Artistry I mean how do you do
it and how do you do it and keep those
performances as rich and as vibrant as
every one of these actors have seen one
of the things that Ryan and I tried very
hard to do was to be very honest in how
the movie was edited and you know to
make sure that if the audience
came back and watched it a second time
they would be delighted by what they
discovered instead of angry because the
movie had lied to them
and you know and the same thing is true
the characters right because it's a
they're a big part of the truth and
honesty of the movie and so we always
had to be very very true to them as well
I mean if you if you watch the movie and
you watch it carefully you're going to
see an awful lot of things in a second
viewing that are there in plain sight
that you you might think you should have
seen but there was really no way you
could
what is I think most interesting about
this is that because of it in addition
to the script you are also having to do
a lot with every bit of dialogue this is
not your average there is scientific
things there is like everything that
you're trying to get across with it but
with your character I think more than
anyone he is somebody who is trying to
hide as much is trying to keep as much
secret I do not want to give too much
away but what was that like sort of
playing with those different looks
because so much of your character I
think is in the face and in the
expressions and in what we're able to
see maybe on a second viewing part of
our first meeting that we had I think
maybe Ryan was worried that I would look
you know like a lot of actors you know
like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] where's
my lines where's my lies you know and
you know that I'd be worried that I
didn't have a lot to say or you know as
much to say to some other people but uh
but I thought like like everybody else
he had threaded Lionel through so
beautifully and when he did say
something it was impactful and I just
and once I really started thinking about
the relationships and the tension and
the complication I knew that there was
so much that he was feeling all the time
so you know I when I graduated college
all I all I wanted was to be a part of
some theater company in Chicago or you
know or Seattle or something you know
and I and I'd you know maybe get to play
two great Parts a year you know in a
community that appreciated what I do and
and I it dawned on me like a year ago
that that's kind of like when you get to
a certain point in Hollywood that's kind
of what this town is you know it's a rap
territory company and if you're lucky
you get a couple calls a year where you
get to play these different parts and uh
and and it's a it's just um a real gift
as a performer it's not about the size
of the part you know it's about the
collaborators the people that you're
working with the you know if you're
appreciated and and you can make
something special together which is what
we did so anyway I I felt just as
invested you know every single moment if
I wasn't talking whatever I mean I was
we we had connections we had stuff to
work out
and I would say like I say again there's
everything in this there's little
details in every single one of these
characters that are interesting to watch
a second time around Ryan I want to
bring it back to you sir because so much
of this was in the writing it was in the
script but each one of these characters
feel completely three-dimensional yeah
no it's it's all right then kind of to
the needs of the story I mean anything
in terms of them think through feeling
three-dimensional the the balance
especially when you're writing of
knowing or hoping that you're gonna get
um incredible actors to be in each of
these parts and there is
well I don't think it's meta but there
is a part of your brain that is thinking
I want to justify each one of these
people showing up I want to give that
every single actor shows up I want to
give them something to chew on and to
dig in dig into that's gonna be worthy
of their talents and worth their time
and so you try and do that on the pitch
but the reality is it's only when
everyone shows up you can start reading
through it and you really start
discovering because it does live in the
in between spaces it doesn't live just
in the lines that they have in the
script it lives in how they embody the
character how they work with Jenny Egan
the costume designer and and and how
they bring those characters to life and
how they observe so much of this these
movies are listening
um you know so much of these movies with
whodunits are reaction shots and
characters listening to other characters
and seeing how they react to that and
there are so many Beautiful Moments in
it but that's the beauty of writing
that's also part of the pleasure of
writing uh whodunit is it is by its
nature and an ensemble and there's
something incredible joyful about that
especially when you have world-class
actors any one of whom have and could
carry their own film showing up with the
joyful intent of truly coming together
as an ensemble to play and that requires
incredible amount of talents and an
incredible
amount of Grace and it just leads it so
far with both of the films and this one
you know as well just it's just led to
an incredible experience well one
oscar-nominated effort and more to come
hopefully I want to remind everyone that
Knives Out Glass Onion is available for
voting in all categories and I want to
thank all of you for watching guys thank
you so much for coming thank you guys so
much thank you
[Applause]